a dramatic turn of events for Alec
Baldwin nearly a year after
cinematographer Helena Hutchins was
tragically shot on the rust movie Set
welcome everyone to Entertainment
Tonight You know the big headline today
Helena's family and Alec reaching a
settlement in the wrongful death lawsuit
but the most surprising news was yet to
come
there's only one question to ask here
who put a live round in the gun it's
supposed to be a cold gun hard to
believe but Alec is expected to resume
filming rust in January are you doing
okay no I'm not actually that's right
the movie still plans to be released
and there's another twist while
financial terms have not been made
public Helena's husband Matthew Hutchins
has been named an executive producer of
rust he was spotted out on Monday
running errands in La I had I had been
overcome by this anger it's an Abrupt
shift for Matthew who was outraged by
Alex sit down with ABC News you're never
supposed to point a gun at anyone on a
set no matter what unless the person is
the cinematographer hearing him blame
Helena in the interview are we really
supposed to feel bad about you
while the civil settlement is good news
for Alec there's still the criminal case
and charges could come any day now last
week A New Mexico D.A filed paperwork
indicating she may prosecute up to four
people in the case
Alec who allegedly fired the handgun is
reportedly one of the potential
defendants that could be facing a jury
trial do you feel guilt no no I don't
know if this is suspected blood or real
blood oh this is fake why would anybody
believe that I worked in this business
for 40 years and that day I decided to
play with a gun that's the dumbest thing
I've ever heard Baldwin of course
already has a lot on his plate that's
the worst drum roll I've ever heard the
64 year old and his wife ilaria welcomed
baby number seven last month ilario
posted this new family portrait and this
morning she shared the sweetest pics of
the newborn whose first name is
pronounced just like hers illaria which
means happy ready to not have a baby in
my belly anymore me too me too mommy's
tired